reece kinnear is on the mound getting
his second start with the padres and
reece kinnear the big right-hander 24
year old throws the four seamer a split
change a cutter and a slider an era
about eight and a half hopefully he can
lower that this afternoon see if he
challenges him with heaters today strike
three that was on a changeup first
strikeout of the day fort caneer two
down and that was a dandy it's his
second best pitch and he really
has some good arm swing on that there's
the grip and there's the result with a
little bit of tilt down and in big
league pitch right there two outs bases
empty just under way
one one pitch story centered in the air
straight away center mariznick out there
making his padre debut drifts back into
the right center field gap jake makes
the catch and a one two three top of the
first for reese kneel austin gobber has
been filling up the zone comes in with a
record of eight and five and a 369
earned run average jake mariznick in his
padres debut stands in
strike three oh
wow didn't have to be
a novice has the play today rung him up
jake marisik just got the bat taken
right out of his hands taking some
pitches down and in that one is
definitely off the plate gomber gets the
call two on one away sets the table
nicely for jake cronenworth
lying to right center field that's a
gapper up the alley
from second comes frazier he'll score
here comes machado
he'll score
it's a two-run double for jake
croninworth and the padres take a
two-nothing lead the first inning
pitcher's got to be careful pitching to
jake cronenworth because you're going to
enter another dimension
not only of sight and sound but of mind
and jake cronenworth getting in the mind
of austin gomber there the breaky ball
down away look at the play coverage
to the pull side
and that is a nice way to wake up this
sunday crowd downtown
splitting the right center field gap and
putting two on the board so the bases
are loaded ha sung getting the started
shortstop today play the offensive play
it's time to get greedy 2-1 pitch hit on
a line deep down the left field line
that is a fair ball that will go to the
corners that's going to get at least a
couple in
nola will be held at third myers and
cronenworth cross the plate and for the
second time this inning a two run double
this one belongs to kim and it's four to
nothing padres in the first we've been
talking about hassan kim gradually
getting better at velocity it bears some
fruit here fastball middle in spins on
it hassan loves that left field line
keeps it fair
cronenworth comes in
myers comes in padres up four nothing
here in the first and now both guys who
have walked this inning have come in the
sport the rockies without a base runner
so far two outs hillyard
and now this ball is crushed to right
center field get up get out
gone
i was going to say sam hilliard's going
to get opportunities here in the last
couple of months and he's earned them by
what he's done since his return he earns
a little bit more street cred with
another long ball his fifth came off the
bat at basically 110 miles an hour it's
four to one yeah and his third home run
pretty good road trip all things
considered getting more regular playing
time the pinch hit homer against the
angels the other night and got a pitch
that stayed out over the plate and he
says liftoff here i come huey 18th home
run on this 10 game road trip
gomber will not go out for the second
inning it'll be uh ashton goudeau the
rocky's just reacquired a couple of days
ago from cincinnati for cash
tommy pham manny with a base hit and a
run scored in the first inning 2-2 pitch
swaying and a miss got him on a high
fastball away two strikeouts and a one
two three second for ashton gudeau
ashton godeau has been making the rounds
this year that's for sure second stint
with the rockies was with the club the
second half of april 1-2 pitch is hit
through the left side and into left
field for a base hit
first major league hit for austin godeau
and it comes with one out in the third
oh one pitch ground ball second base
frazier will tag out gudeau throw to
first in time double play nicely done by
adam frazier who doesn't waste any time
making a decision and turns the inning
ending to twin killing no runs a hit by
gudeau and nobody left mariznick is at
second base with one away eric hosmer
pinch hitting
there's a liner to left field for hosmer
it's in for a base hit
from second mariznick will score throw
to second base and hosmer
in safely
padres have their four run lead back
again on top five to one
pitch it doubled for eric hosmer a
little soft serve the left
off the end of the bat he went the
opposite way
and mariznick scoring easily hosmer
smelling two runner on second one out
for myers
up the middle and under the glove of
rogers coroner is coming around throw
playwood will be late padres take a 6-1
lead rbi single for will myers and the
padres have a five-run lead
boy will is so big and strong he fights
this one off
in the positioning of the rockies as you
can see rogers
just under the glove the short hop got
him bobby dickerson sends jake not even
close he scampers home and the friars
add on hassan kim leads it off in the
bottom of the sixth and drives one to
deep left field
back goes joe
back goes the ball gone
upper deck for hot sun kim padres seven
to one sixth home run of the big leagues
for kim 4c fastball he is all over it
and sending it on its way and assang kim
was waiting on bomb the left center
second deck padres continue to add runs
7-1 padre austin had the bloop single in
the first lined out to center in his
last at-bat cronin worth it first
machado at third
to left field connor joe
makes the catch over towards the corner
tagging at third is machado he will
score the eighth padres run austin nola
with a sac fly and it's 8-1 san diego
miguel diaz recall from trip roy el paso
saturday for the sixth time this season
in the big leagues enters his 18th game
joe at first story at second one away
strict recall got him looking two down
in the ninth inning got him with the
change up after going 95 96 89 right at
the top now diaz comes set two balls and
two strikes to garrett hampson pitch
from diaz swung on and missed strike
three in the ball game is over miguel
diaz with back to back kays to close out
the ninth inning and close out this
series against the colorado rockies